J is with us in Florida
hi J welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
better than I deserve what's up you know
I use this statement everywhere I go if
people ask me that I'm like oh you know
just better than I deserve
they're like save my life yeah well I
have a student scholarship that turned
into a dead fat cat collection without
my knowledge and I wanted your advice on
which way and how to deal with the
situation it was a scholarship and it
turned into a dad how can that happen
well when you go into the service the
first year is free the second year you
pay for and if you decide to get out of
the program it now turns into a debt if
you have to repay the scholarship money
the service the military yeah yes the
military yes really I didn't know that
okay so you quit school and your
scholarship turned into a debt well I
didn't quit school I just with program I
continue school and I was told that when
I'm finished with school I would have to
pay back the money so ever when I was
finished with school I got I all of a
sudden I did my first class return and I
know that I would spent a collection
without my knowledge
okay well that's not a big deal just
play it off well I I died what happened
was the interest in collection fees it
all came up so now I have the extras
almost 15 grand that I didn't did you
say 50 grand 15 1 1 5 how much did you
how much was the scholarship for that it
turned into a loan I was about 20 20 mm
okay and how long ago was this this was
five years ago time you knew when you
quit the sir
had become alone right I did yeah so why
is it a surprise to you that when you
didn't pay on it for five years it went
into collections no it went into
collection while I was in school why
didn't you start paying it as soon as
you got out of school just like my I
have another school debt and they sent a
letter with all the information and
everything that I'm supposed to do I
wasn't given any other information on
how I'm supposed to do and I do know
it's my fault Dave I'm supposed to go
after it I'm supposed to you know what's
supposed to happen because it's my debt
however I guess what I'm saying is it
someone you can negotiate away the
collection fees fifteen thousand and
collection fees is ridiculous on a
twenty thousand dollar debt there will
be some interest to that you can't
negotiate away because it's been five
years on twenty thousand but and so some
of that fifteen thousand maybe as much
as half of it will be actually interest
and because it is a debt that's been
outstanding that interest is not they're
not going to negotiate that if it's a
guaranteed federal federal if it became
a federal guaranteed student loan which
is what it sounds like it sounds like it
dropped into the Sallie Mae program and
so yeah you've just got it go in and
address it you can negotiate a way the
the the collections fees and and get on
a payment plan with them as far as the
IRS holding your refunds they're gonna
do that as long as you're in default on
a student loan there's not there's
nothing you can do about that except
make your w-2 be changed to where you
don't have refunds anymore which would
be a great idea as well you shouldn't be
getting a tax refund to start with so
but the money that they took this year
it's gonna be applied to the debt and
it's gone
so there's not a negotiation with the
IRS on this it's a direction that they
get from Congress to take your money and
put it on the student loan and they
don't even ask so that's I'm sorry but
that's exactly how it works so the good
news is now you've got all the numbers
and you can get the whole thing lined up
and you can get an attack mode
and you can begin to work your way
through it